un contrôle maladrerie point coupole à
but pour toi à ce point de contrôle
robespierre début de l'opération journée
sans poids lourds à poissy vingt
policiers une quinzaine d'élus et
bénévoles se sont retrouvés pour former
différentes équipes mobilisées sur trois
barrages filtrants pour nous c'est une
première il s'agit d'interdire la
circulation des poids lourds en transit
sur la commune donc sur trois axes
principaux
nous allons procéder à un contrôle des
poids lourds qui vont entrer sur la
commune
nous allons leur demander s'ils
effectuent une livraison sur la sur le
territoire communal et si c'est le cas
ils pourront passer si c'est pas le cas
ils seront invités à faire dès
maintenant en particulier continue comme
ça je serai diabolisée systématiquement
depuis 2014 la ville a déjà verbalisé
plus 2100 poids lourds boulevard
robespierre les équipes sensibilise les
conducteurs de camions comme deux
voitures une priorité pour la commune
c'est plus d'un poids lourds toutes les
minutes qui est ici et c'est 70 % de
poids lourds qui prennent la ville de
poissy pour une zone de transit c'est
au-delà même de ce que j'imaginais
c'est insupportable parce qu'ils n'ont
pas le droit d'être là mais c'est
insupportable parce qu'elle est la
pollution
évidemment à la clé et c'est
insupportable parce que sa gangrène
l'autre trafic interne à la ville de
poissy
donc on veut dire stop nous avons
constaté quand même un nette
augmentation de la circulation de poids
lourds en particulier est traversé à des
vitesses quand même assez importante et
pour nous ça devient très problématique
même de rester dans cet appartement
à tel point qu'on se pose la question
comme 80% des habitants maurice souhaite
le contournement de la ville de poissy
ce type d'opération devrait être
renouvelée le maire prévoit d'organiser
des assises de la mobilité et du
transport à la rentrée